you saw last year when Jerry sadowitz
was canceled at the Edinburgh Fringe the
the statement that was put out by the
Pleasants theater trust and bear in mind
this is one of the biggest comedy
Platforms in the world really the
pleasant they said they couldn't
tolerate the opinions that he was
expressing on stage he wasn't expressing
opinions he didn't Express a single
opinion they're called jokes and if the
key figures principal figures within the
comedy industry don't know what jokes
are and they don't I mean television's
the same but you had the the BBC
streaming service has a version of
Faulty Towers the version that you watch
of the episode called the Germans when
you watch that famous episode there is a
scene removed on the BBC people at the
BBC don't understand the joke they don't
understand how Comedy Works so they've
taken the scene out either that or they
have this very patronizing view that the
audience won't understand how Comedy
Works and they feel they need to protect
them